[Música]
e chan tat este ano ia chutar deixou
saudades
[Música]
ó andré xandão já tão pedra
o vôo o ladrão pra quebra quebra
já clique em gostei no começo do vídeo
você não esquecer que toda vez que deixa
o final se estão curtos vídeos
carregados em sair e no clube gosto
então aproveita agora porque gostei vai
ficou não tão que já se inscreve no
canal a itabom ali ray agora explique em
inglês
eu voltei da europa o último show foi
dublê de dança' em 18 dias fazendo um
show na europa quase que estava me
acostumando já cheguei no brasil pelo
picolé quase joguei a embalar o lixo
quase cheio disputei meu deus eu estou
fazendo aqui é brasil é brasil porras
admin saneamento básico saúde e educação
site só voltei como doente é lógico que
o piauí é campeão e este vai pra europa
e não volta gripado no hotel e ronfe da
desgraça que meu deus que essa desgraça
não foi a desgraça é um ser humano tá tá
louco falando aqui de graça tá frio fez
a desgraça normal ou normal das
desgraças graciato desgraça eu só
desgraça e aí tô aqui com a garganta
desgraçada eu gravar o meu dvd venderam
especial de comédia que os judeus e de
culto e vendendo bem mas vou gravar o
especial comary no rio de janeiro dia 2
de dezembro jeneci arenas e não comprou
seu ingresso é neste site já pode
adquirir que já está acabando foi
abordado também duas semanas então
compilados o ingresso vai lá no dvd e
voltei estou aqui pela mata que tudo eu
não posso explicar eu inspiro muito
escândalo face achatada meu espírito é
um problema para um problema no meu
espírito é altura em que o organismo se
contenta com o espírito só não se não
for no mínimo 3 a som som as pessoas vão
falar comigo fiquei interrompeu isso já
viu que ele dizendo já viu aquele
deserto já viu o que ele nega
este tipo de espírito e will surpresa
aqueles que você não sabia que tinha
qatar vão catar você está sentindo nada
vocês viu mais um catar para que saiu da
médula você faz aqui o negócio verde que
dava pra minha mãe o meu prêmio nikkei
subiu de velho meu amigo espirro tivesse
você acha que vocês piloto ou espiritual
o dever e quebra todas as barreira do
som seis horas a prestar atenção num voo
de você espirrando
bom não é
acho que isso vai me escutar o espírito
dele no bota fé que expirou é como ver
mesmo tempo de escutar e espiritual e tv
que prepara o espírito que tem jeito tem
que preparar os pilotos e quando expira
três vezes dessa altura pior porque o
último espírito é mais forte que os
outros dois do tipo especial que
apareceu um pastor que nunca viu vai
fazer isso aqui é minha casa
kaká eo contínuo que aquele que eu tenho
medo quando veio foi fácil
aquelas pessoas que precisam nariz aqui
para não para não sair com do nariz que
eu fico meio que sem uma campanha de
defesa e alguém me disse que não pode
fazer isso aquilo que faz pressão nas v
do sério pode estourar pessoa morre mas
gira pessoa morreu e do espirro ou tac
para o meu irmão morreu do espanhol
ficou muito putado eu fico muito puto se
eu morrer de inspirar a mãe ea irmã dele
parece ter morrido spin-off tão puto que
eu fui pro céu nem entro fica na porta
os caras me chamando embora a editar no
céu barulho não também levantaram
desgarro morrer três bioma e morro e do
espirro apontar e emoção e irmãos e
grita grita desgraça está na vida da
gente do sai nessa merda aqui fica um
pouco com gripe a com que a vida voltou
a baixar a bola da gente sabia quem está
se achando e mais a vida facilitada se
acham de maio o jogador no corpo dele
aqui e baixar essa bolinha dengue com
gripe mas de café nada só quer dormir do
grupo direto de vancouver seu sou a
pessoa facilmente eu fico doente fique
doente muito fácil eu acho que a gripe
só pega e outras pessoas que não me
conhecem direito público é o seguinte o
single coisa bateu sob a poeira é livre
para quem chega os amigos nutrição diz
que tem dois tipos e amigo aparece
quando você está doente a nutricionista
que sabe tudo que tem que comer eo
médico pensamentos desaparece
com isso você está cuidando do seu corpo
de totó cuidando do meu corpo sim o do
meu corpo
é a pizza kombis e sanduíche gomes a
luiz mas é que você pode substituir
essas coisas por alguma coisa saudável é
por exemplo tem um sanduíche fitch a
[ __ ] que pariu sanduíche fitch é meu só
você me respeite e sanduíche é um
propósito só matar propósito é esse você
tira esse propósito sanduíche já não é
mais sobre a história de que substitui
as coisas ainda ok fui lá no lugar fitch
vamos lá ver como é que é falar
almoçando e shift ac dc que vai contar
sobre edith aparência que é 75 reais eu
falei você não quer meu bem você não
quer que eu viva não da ge não tem como
ser saudável no mundo não têm como é o
foi o seu nicho seu nicho fazer o exame
aqui sabe como é que eu faço para cuidar
do meu corpo fez o exame é o que a
gordura no fígado eu falei meu deus eu
nem sabia que dava para ter gordura no
fígado a mulher desceu e se você está
com gordura no fígado isso mas se você
está cuidando do seu filho à vontade
setor
quando corri direto nunca tirei meu
filho pra nada outro lugar que eu vou
levo meu filho do corpo dele como
ninguém com ninguém ou uma mãe
volta e meia tem que deixar o final pra
fazer outra coisa eu levo meu filho a
todo lugar que passou já passei eu
fiquei puto já no início tão rápido tem
que substituir as coisas por uma coisa
mais saudável e lá comprar o negócio o
papamel chega lá você quer um mel a
fauna ou sequer como assim como eu quero
mas mel e mel carácter diferença é de
mel como abelha aqui que bebe coca faz
mel com cachaça não que tem o mel
orgânico tem um mel processado e tenho o
mel do extrato do mel e você olha eu
quero meo meo boca é o melhor mel que a
senhora tiver eu quero quero mel da
simone e simaria que mel que a bíblia
sempre volta quando é bom eu quero aqui
esse é o oitavo e saudável é complicado
fazer com que o capital se você fala
pizza aparece na mesa e deu a diferença
é essa diferença é que o meu x enfarto
daquele que vem o saque por óleo daqui
da esquina tem agora sal e do himalaia é
saber o himalaia meu nome é na [ __ ]
aquela merda e teu amigo médico neto
amigo médico que se apuraram que os
agrupamentos pode ser o seu parecer
gengibre chupo gengibre amanhã tu tá
bozinho daquela boca cala a boca que é
que tu sabe do estoque do em neves está
perguntou assim porque eu sou homem
homem é desse jeito é dramático é bom
cortar doença pode ter certeza que tenha
muito tempo ela está sentindo alguma
coisa só depois que ela vai falar
contigo ela suporta minha mãe tem 30
anos a cabeça dói 30 anos nunca tomou
doril toda aquela foi minha cabeça é
doente e vai viver a vida dora homem ao
mar e doeu barriga
a mãe chora peidró da empresa lançou o
meo dramático ou amanhã em espremer um
cravo cara não sai sai
não não não não tirou a e tirou amor
também também sua retórica sua renda na
cara da gente e tomara que eu fique bem
né e não esquece clicar em gostei aqui
tá aproveite e tá vendo e ouvindo o que
estou falando agora dessa embaixo clique
em gostei da eu quero você comente aqui
embaixo que você tem mais raiva com você
fica doente que mais acontece quando
você fica doente começa aqui em baixo no
facebook quem vem do facebook curte quem
vem no twitter e dar rt quem vai gastar
grand curte a fama dos reis quem vem do
inep aproveite fica por aqui que o snap
ninguém está fazendo nada né morreu de
gripe no gráfico meu show no rio de
janeiro dia 2 de dezembro a gravação do
especial é meu dever pt
na descrição do vídeo redes sociais
também estamos juntos se inscrevem no
canal meu protetor valeu